[Music]
speech at google it it's been a long
journey
so we originally developed voice search
for for Google search I think it was
over 15 years ago and then we we kind of
took that technology and brought it to
other products like Google Maps for for
search in maps for navigation and
text-to-speech for for for navigation
and captions in YouTube and Google
assistant and sort of we invested all
that effort into building a robust
speech engine that can work across a
large number of languages and doesn't
need as much tuning is technology that
existed at the time all based on machine
learning and then we took that
technology three years ago and we
brought it to the cloud for the first
time with cloud speech-to-text as part
of our developer products can we go back
slides
[Laughter]
yeah it's okay so speech to text and
then text to speech there are developer
products so you can use them to you know
power all the applications you build
with AI technology and then last year we
introduced our business solutions which
are higher level of abstraction which
include dialogue flow and contact center
AI there's going to be a session about
those tomorrow so you're welcome to
check it out they take some of the
technologies we expose in speech to text
and text to speech and apply them to
specific use cases like chat BOTS and
voice spots and and the contact center
so you could use them in more places so
as I mentioned we have two products in
cloud with with the raw speech
capabilities that are sort of leveraged
everywhere else speech to text is
available in 120 languages
so far more than any other speech
service that's that's available today
and it provides service in real-time
streaming as well as batch one of the
things that special it performs really
well in noisy environments will see if
I'm regret saying that when we actually
do some demos later but typically it's
it's trained on a lot of noisy data so
it performs well even if there's traffic
in the background or or people speaking
or whatever and Texas speech it's the
only production service out there with
wavenet well we'll see later why that
actually matters it's available in 21
languages but there's going to be more
coming later and Texas and SML so since
we first came out with speech detects
there's there's been a lot of new
development in this space as you can see
here we took it to GA we improved
accuracy we improve the speed and then
we introduced a bunch of new features
like language order detect word level
confidence timestamps then in February
so two months ago we came out with a
bunch of new launches and I'm going to
talk a little bit more about them next
so we wanted to make our speech products
more accessible and we're doing that in
three ways one is we're making the
premium models that were only available
to select group now available to
everyone too we're reducing prices on on
some of our products by up to 50% and
three were increasing language support
especially for a text-to-speech so a
little bit on the premium model so as I
mentioned the core speech recognition
technology in cloud was based on the
technology that Google developed for
other products but what we quickly find
out is the cloud developers weren't just
applying them on the same use cases that
Google search or Google assistant or
other Google products used but actually
for a lot of enterprise
application so like transcribing phone
calls for IVRS or for indexing videos or
adding subtitles to videos or
transcribing meetings or all these other
use cases and so we invested specific
effort for improving these cloud models
and this resulted in our premium models
that were launched in beta I think it
was April last year so exactly one year
ago so these these premium models
improve performance by 64 percent and 62
percent so this is the percentage of
reduction in errors so you could argue
it's you know two to three X better than
what existed before for these specific
mediums because there was a concerted
effort on on these areas and then when
they when they launched the enhanced
phone call model was based on data from
opt-in customers in cloud that gave us
the permission to use their data to
improve the models so we only made it
available for others that also
contributed for for that program but
then and now we're sort of opening it up
further so so I'll talk a little bit
more about that but but first let's
switch to the demo I can show you guys
we get a lot of questions from people
about oh I think it's showing the wrong
screen do I need to change something and
actually maybe I drag it that's no
that's the wrong one switchback yeah
maybe if I drag my screen over here so
that work
oh sorry guys let me change my display
settings so that it's mirrored
justplease okay
I think it's showing now so a lot of
people ask us they tell us you know we
we already sort of use speech
recognition when we know that Google
speech recognition is better but you
know what we have is good enough for us
what's happening is speech recognition
is used in more and more use cases today
and the bar is actually getting higher
so you can see here this is an example
of a conversation with the voice bot
where you're getting 100% accuracy and
you can see you can build a very
delightful experience for users when
everything is working properly right so
this is an example of someone ordering a
burger and the Vice bot responding and
everything works great but then you if
you go down to a lower level of accuracy
even at 90% which you know for harsh
conditions is actually considered pretty
good that means in a UH pterence with 40
words you'll get four of them wrong
and there's a very high likelihood that
those four words some of them will
encompass things that you actually
really care about and the bots will will
will fail which will lead the users to
be a little frustrated because they they
actually need to repeat stuff that
they've already said before so it's not
it's not a great user experience and
this is even at ninety percent but then
imagine what would happen if this goes
down and a little bit further into
eighty percent right you'll see that in
a second it's it becomes sort of
inoperable right and so if you were to
say a few years ago 80 or 90 percent
accuracy for recognizing speech people
would be pretty happy but now there's
there's um there's a higher bar for this
by the way this also applies to Google
products right so with Google assistant
the bar for voice recognition is much
higher than it used to be when when we
were doing voice search
okay let's go back to the slides okay so
the premium models for a better speech
recognition the phone one was only
available for people that share audio
now we've made it available for everyone
and then for people that enable data
logging as an opt-in feature they're now
all getting discounted usage so
everyone's getting a benefit whether
they share data or don't share data
we're here to provide the best service
either way cool let's talk a little bit
about text-to-speech so we introduced
cloud text-to-speech that's based on
wherever net last year you can see here
a survey we ran on the quality of the
voices and what you see here is four
different voices and the left left
column shows the standard voice the
middle is the wavenet and the right one
is human so if you look at the yellow
one for example which is the third the
standard is three point six five the
human is four point 59 you can see
wavenet is 4.28 so it's really really
close let's switch to the demos so if we
go here and we type something like hi to
the audience the session of Google Cloud
Next and now let me play this to you
guys with this is now standard techni
standard voice hi to the audience of the
session of Google Cloud Next
so you can see you can hear what he says
very clearly right you can understand
every single word but it sounds a little
robotic hi to the audience of the
session of Google Cloud Next now if we
switch to the wavenet equivalent hi to
the audience at the session of
Google cloud next so you can see it's
it's a worlds apart right and when you
use this for a long long text and play
it I I sometimes can't tell the
difference it sounds to me like an NPR
news product broadcaster right it's it's
it's getting pretty close to to what we
would hear on the radio or whatever back
to the slides
so wavenet is really cool but the
problem is it's hugely compute-intensive
so in order to generate a wave net
sample for every single second of audio
we need to run 22,000 inferences on a
very heavy neural network and that was a
huge engineering challenge originally it
took a long time to do but then our team
spent a pretty significant effort
figuring out how to optimize it and the
the Google team came up with a way to do
it a thousand times faster and this is
building on the sort of infinite compute
power we have with GPUs tensor
processing units and other things that
are sort of ml unless ml specialized it
lets you run much much faster and much
better and we were able to do it at
scale in a way that you know it's not
possible in the industry and and then
just a few weeks ago we announced a huge
expansion of our voices so we've now
doubled the number of wavenet voices and
if you look back to April last year we
had six wavenet voices only in English
us we now have 57 wavenet voices I think
in pretty much all of the languages you
see here and there's going to be more
coming soon later in the year so we have
full coverage so it's by far more than
anything else that that's out there very
very excited about wavenet in the future
and then to wrap it up the other
announcement we had was a bunch of
features
when GA which means general availability
that that means that they're covered
under our SLA agreement and are
considered sort of production-ready so
text-to-speech as a product when when GA
last year and then audio profiles which
lets you tune the the text-to-speech
audio to the medium and a bunch of these
speech to text features model selection
our premium models multi-channel
recognition audio logging
okay so to make this interesting we
wanted to talk to you a little bit about
new features that are about to come soon
now this is not something we sort of
typically do in all of our sessions here
at next but we wanted to keep it
interesting for you guys and give you a
sense of what's coming next the the
balance of it is some of these things
that might change before you actually
see them sort of officially launched out
in production so you know we we would
love to still hear your feedback if you
have any ideas of how to improve these
but we're going to show you how they
look like right now so we're going to
talk about sort of the two main groups
of use cases that we serve with speech
recognition so the first is
human-computer interaction that's kind
of the traditional investment of speech
at Google and then the second is human
or human and attract interaction so you
could think about you know analyzing
phone calls between a customer and an
agent or analyzing meetings or things
like that
where where you're we're talking about
speech between multiple people so we're
gonna have new developments for each of
these two to talk about a little bit
let's start with the first one so we've
had something called phrase hints in our
API for for a long while now
the problem is it's really hard to get
it right right so sorry actually let me
first describe what it does what phases
does is it allows you to customize the
API to specific phrases so if you have
specific product names or company names
or other things that you're looking for
there you expect users might say you can
add that
the recognition command and then it will
improve recognition quality the trouble
is it could also increase false
positives right if you add a string it
might start recognizing that string even
if it wasn't said so the by default it's
actually it's set to be pretty weak
right so that's a problem the other
problem is you know you need to sort of
come up with different phrases for for
everything you wanna you want to send so
we're we're gonna come out with a few
features that that address this first is
what we call strength so as you can see
in blue over there we're going to give
you the opportunity to set the strength
for each speech context and so you can
you can set it much stronger than what
you what we made available up until now
and it makes it much more useful you'll
be able to see that in a demo in a few
minutes
the second is classes so for things like
month for example you know you if you
just tell us that you're looking for a
month we can figure out what's what's
behind it you don't need to spell out
all of the different months January and
February etc so here's an example list
of classes and we'll share the final one
when when this is when this is ready to
go but um these can help you with your
different recognition test okay let's
switch to the demo
okay here it is so here just as an
example there's a sequence of digits
that that we recorded let me play it to
you three one three seven eight six five
four so you could kind of understand
what what I'm saying in this recording
then if you look at this other one you
can see it's very noisy so it's actually
really hard to tell what the digits are
okay so if you if you take the original
one let me just change this if you take
the original one and you send it to the
API then we'll see it's it recognizes it
properly with 100% accuracy recognizing
a digit C Queen it's pretty hard by the
way right because even if you get one
one of them wrong the whole string is
wrong right so in a way it's it's like a
full sentence now let's try the same on
the noisy one so I just sent a curl
command like you see here and you can
see it it recognizes it incorrectly so
it says we went three seven eight six
five four because it doesn't really know
that it should expect a sequence of
digits so here what I'm going to do is
I'm going to use the class operand which
means a digit I'm going to tell it it
should expand the sequence of eight
consecutive digits I'm going to send it
over and you can see it's it still
didn't change the result the reason is
still using relatively weak speech
context so now when I also add strength
high like you can see here in blue
what can try it again and you can see
now it actually recognizes it with 100%
accuracy so so that's speech conflict
strength and classes guys
so just just as a disclaimer like it
doesn't always work right speech
recognition is it's kind of a little bit
of a science in a little bit of an all
right there's going to be cases where
you you wanna force it to recognize
digits but it'll recognize something
else there and there's gonna be cases
where it recognizes are too strong right
so you it falsely recognizes digits when
you don't want it to so these are kind
of things that allow you a little bit
more control to play with the API and
reach the settings that are optimal for
you so for each use case it might be a
little different okay let's talk about
the second major use case which is human
to human interaction and there we've had
streaming for for a long period of time
but streaming is limited to one minute
we do have long-running recognized they
could use any sort of length that you
want but it doesn't it doesn't work in
real time right but the problem is
speech analytics usually requires long
audio files so if it's a phone call
recording it could be 5 minutes or 10
minutes if it's a meaning it could be
multiple hours if the movie could be
multiple hours so what we're coming out
with is a new feature called result end
time and what it does it tells you how
far the recognition happened so far and
then you can restart a new session from
where the last one ended so you can
restart a session whenever you want and
and still get a hundred percent of the
same sort of results as if you were
going more so let me show you how this
actually looks like in real life ok so
what you see here in this demo I can
make this maybe a bit bigger here we
asked it to restart every 10 seconds so
every 10 second it basically closes the
streaming connection and starts a new
streaming connection so right now the
API supports up to 60 seconds so if I
didn't use any time I would just
go up until 60 but in order to make the
demo more interesting we set it to 10 to
make it easier I'm gonna click start and
now you can see it's listening to me
and it's showing these red boxes so the
red box you can see is turning into
green once I it detects an end of an
utterance it's not a good combination
with which we talking in the echo I get
I see but you you can see the it's
turning into green once once of the text
and end of utterance and you can slice
the red the yellow box is show when
where it's restarting and so you can see
the actual audio is not impacted by when
it restarts if I keep on talking now you
can see that it keeps on the recognition
even though it's a whole new streaming
session right it keeps on with all of
the same data that it had so you can you
can see it carries over right so with
this method you can basically do endless
streaming for for as long as you want
let me show you how that looks like um
in the command line mode so I'm gonna
talk now and now I'm gonna talk again
and let's see okay you can see it did a
restart and it didn't impact the
recognition by the way I was a-standing
that the mic is on my laptop I was
standing a little further out from phone
from the laptop so that probably reduces
results a little bit wow that was a
really long
okay so thank you
so that's endless streaming how many
developers do we have in the audience
who wants to see kind of the code that's
powering this this demo okay
a lot of hands up there okay let's do it
the only caveat is I I didn't write this
code so I'll do my best to give it
justice but please please forgive me if
I if I don't do it so so this is then
coding node can you guys see her should
I make it bigger is that better
okay let me scroll down to the bottom
because that's where the action is so
here in the bottom you can see what it
does it is it starts a record session
and you use a program called rec which
is from the socks family and it uses
that to capture audio from the mic and
then it sends it into audio stream
transform which is a it's a transform
stream something that's readable and
writeable and then it calls something
called start stream so let's scroll up
to start stream and what start stream
does it starts an audio array and then
it starts a new streaming recognised
session so this is calls the
speech-to-text api and then it sends all
the data that's coming in to speech
callback and then here you set a timeout
so you restart the stream this is the
ten seconds that we had in our demo
let's take a look at speech callback
what's key speech callback does its gets
the result in time from the API this is
what we talked about earlier and then it
calculates the corrected time so here
I'm sorry here in the demo you can see
there's there's a corrector time which
is you need to know that it's sixty
seconds from when we started the demo
not just the
the offset from from where we currently
are in the Curan or a so calculates
calculates that and and prints it out
and then it looks about it looks for in
is final if it gets is final that's the
flag that says that end of utterance was
detected so you can mark it as green or
otherwise it keeps on it keeps using the
same audio buffer and then marks it as
red and so then let's also look at the
callback that's another kind of
interesting important one so here what
it does is calculate what we call chunk
time it's basically the size of an audio
array element so you take the the full
streaming limit divided by the length of
the audio array and then you get like
what is the size is each element in the
array or a chunk and then with that
chunk you you calculate the how many
chunks you need to grab from sort of the
previous array and how many how many
chunks you need to grab from from the
current array right so last up audio
length this this tells you it's like
here you can see you need this part
right when you go after the yellow part
you go to this part you need to grab the
audio that came before the yellow so
that's what's being done here you take
it from last audio array and then and
then you and then you and then you
recognize it and then the last important
thing to watch out for is this restart
function so it's really important to run
remove listener if you don't do that
then you'll have to listener is running
in the background so every time you
restart the stream you need to remove
lesson or not just set it to null and
that's it it just you know there's a
restart counter so it knows how many
time's it did 10 seconds and and that's
it so that's a endless streaming guys
thanks so just to talk a little bit
about kind of limitations with the demo
you just saw so it handles two arrays
right to audio arrays and so and and we
set each one to ten seconds you can set
them for longer if you want but in this
demo if you talk more than 20 seconds at
a time it won't be able to capture that
because it's only set up to capture 20
seconds the other thing is that it sort
of does arithmetic on the audio array
based on the length of time that is
passed so it works well for constant
bitrate so linear 16 is fine Mueller is
also fine even though it's compressed
it's still constant bitrate but if you
try like mp3 and stuff like that it
won't work you know luckily there is
very little sort of real-time streaming
that people do with mp3 right because
you'd have to compress it in real time
as well and the other thing to note Dyer
is Asian context is actually important
and if you restored a stream it resets
that context so if you want to do
terrorization this this will impact
those results the other thing is this
this is available here in the node.js
client library we're going to add it to
all of our client libraries eventually
but they're not all available yet so
this this is something that you know is
you'll need to check before you start
using it cool
so let's transition to talk a little bit
about speech analytics so there's
there's a lot of cool things you could
do with with speech analytics especially
in call centers right so understanding
customer sentiment and standing why
users are calling you know figuring out
how do we
Jews call volume or how to upsell you
know like if a customer is asking for a
product that's out of inventory or stuff
like that and you want to follow up
there's like all these cool analyses you
want to do but it's actually non-trivial
too to set it up actually could we
switch to the other slide okay let me go
forward so there's a lot of technical
steps involved and very typically we we
talk to customers they kind of love our
technology they love REI but in order to
actually take advantage of it they need
to sort of go to the IT department and
ask them to build something for them or
they need to hire NSI to both the
physical visualization platform just
just having access to the API is not
enough so we want to help with that and
a way to do that is with what we're
calling the speech analytics framework
so this is kind of like a design pattern
of how to do analysis on speech and this
we're showing an example of how could
apply for the call center but you could
also apply it in in any other use case
so you can see the audio comes in into
Google's cloud storage and then it gets
processed with cloud functions cloud
functions then users are different AI
tools speech API natural language API
auto ml to understand what supports
actually in those audio files and then
that data gets sent through cloud
pub/sub and data flow into bigquery
dataflow handles sort of the streaming
information and then it gets stored in
bigquery which which can do the analysis
it can help us run queries better
understand what's in those audio files
and then we have a visualization layer
the one we're showing here was built in
react but you could build whatever you
want in whatever tool you want and
identity aware proxy for for security
which which kind of leads you to the
final result in the visualization and
you're going to see a demo in a little
bit it's it's it's pretty cool what we
want is for any
customer to be able to get from having
audio files to this in two weeks and
we're setting up a program where you can
ask for help with sis or whatever to
help you sort of get there so to
elaborate a little bit more about that
let me invite Kevin he's gonna it's
gonna talk lots more okay well thank you
Dan it's great to be here and to be able
to talk to you about what we've been
doing it Delta Dental with the tools dan
has been telling us about good yeah
right so we're a health insurance payer
that means we have two large communities
of users the members like URI who get
dental treatment and it's covered by the
plan that's either employer funded or
increasingly ones we fought ourselves on
the individual market under the
dentist's themselves right we cover
about 1.7 million members the bulk of
those obviously are in New Jersey and
Connecticut but we cover people all over
the country for example we have a
hundred thousand members here in
California and we're part of a larger
network of del four dental companies
there are nearly 30 in all which cover
for 73 million Americans and the
association also provides some central
national services the obvious one is
simply a directory of practicing
dentists that we all need to process
claims so why the call center somebody
said in the keynote this morning the
call center is still really the primary
point of contact for many companies for
many of their users and it's
particularly true for us with members
and dentists we do a lot of cause about
4,300 hours a month that's about 4,000
calls a day right and three-quarters of
our calls come from dentists offices and
usually those are questions about
benefits eligibility does this person
who's just walked in the door have
insurance as their insurance expired or
it can get it can get down to the
procedures it's their children's
retainer covered when can I get my crown
all of these kinds of questions come up
in other words what's the coverage in
the plans and as we all know from our
medical and dental experience plans vary
so that's one thing we know from talking
to the customer center the other thing
we know from looking at our phone logs
is that most of our calls are short that
spike you sit in the histogram on the
right is centered on 80 seconds and it's
actually 65 to 95 seconds wide and the
interesting thing about that is that in
that length of time you only have time
to cover one subject so that's a from
the point of view of someone doing a
data science and modeling an analysis
that's a very nice clean data set to
work with and the analytics results I'm
going to show you so far are all based
on analyzing what's going on there in
detail we figured if we understand
single subjects well we'll be able to
get into the more complicated subjects
in the longer course so the first thing
we did was take the speech-to-text from
Dan's tools and run it through the
natural language processing and natural
language the sentiment analysis will
give you back a sentiment score for
every sentence in the in the transcript
and if you really want to test down
stuff try saying that sentence fast ok
and what we then did was marry that back
to the word timings that we get from the
speech-to-text and what the distribution
of sentiment throughout it tracked
through a call and what you can see is
that these are not movie reviews there's
no one number that characterizes the
call what we have though is a great tool
for pulling apart the structure of a
conversation and we can see all the
patterns that you would like to see in
any kind of customer service course show
up immediately in the sentiment right
but it's not very useful for doing
getting quantitative results so what do
you do you have to get a bit more subtle
what we did was split the calls out by
type of caller so look at the top two
rows first in the left column we have
dental offices and members that we
talked about earlier we have we have the
same sentiment plots for each of those
those
these ones are actually three-month
averages on the right-hand side we plot
the residuals we subtracted the average
sentiment profile from the individual
classes and you can see now we actually
have something that we can model we can
fit a straight line to this data and
it's a pretty good fit the bars and 95%
confidence limits so the two things are
obvious one is that members and dentists
are different either dentists or a
gloomy lot or were continually giving
them bad news about how much of their
procedure they want to do is actually
covered but we're doing quite well with
members and the sentiment is generally
rising through the core the bottom row
it turns out that some of our major
accounts haven't have a specific phone
line for them so we can identify a major
account we give the same number to the
dentists and the members so you'd expect
those calls to split the difference and
they do very nicely so what this is
telling us is not necessarily anything
we can immediately use directly but it
is telling us that there is real
structure in the calls and it is worth
analyzing them in more depth and we're
starting to do one of the things we've
started recently is we've turned on the
premium phone model and we're now
running speaker Dyer ization and so the
next generation of these plots will
actually separate out the sentiment
profile for the caller and the sentiment
profile for the agent talking of agents
you can do the same thing for agents the
first time I showed this plot to our
customer service team leaders I hadn't
anonymized the agent names and the
immediate reaction of one of the team
leaders to the top one was she's no
longer with the company right the you
nice thing about that is that was a huge
win because it gives you instant
credibility with the business user that
the kind of measurements you're making
on this data that have seemed to be very
abstract are actually measuring real
things they're seeing they're in the
cutting that we're dealing with their
employees so nice one the others next
metric we looked at was something that
isn't there the dead air between cores
of conversation has natural
rhythms in it and their pauses they vary
in length this is a standard metric in
call centers obviously want your people
talking or you got asked to do this by
the call center because they had an
agent who was though they noticed had a
lot of dead air a lot of pauses in the
conversation and so you can see that in
the plot on the right the other thing
you can also see is that the call
structure shows up it's in exactly the
same way in that in the dead air the
familiar phrases the opening greeting
and the end of the core we don't pause
very much when we're thinking about
working an issue we do this has been an
enormous ly valuable metric for us we've
used it for in customer service for
coaching agents we have done tests
instrumenting the decks the agents
desktop and being able to show that our
agents in the long pauses when they're
working an issue are looking at
applications like sticky notes and
Outlook they're looking up information
in their personal knowledge repositories
that tells us what we have to build next
for them we also instrumented it to show
to test whether dual monitors would
improve so we can quantitatively see
impacts in the customer center just from
these very simple measurements and
that's one of the points that I hope
comes out of this that once you have all
the sophisticated technology of
speech-to-text and natural language
you're able to ask very simple business
oriented questions and get good answers
another metric we've worked on topic
modeling but we haven't yet got any very
good results and we're about to go
through another iteration of that topic
modeling for us is really hard because
you saw we had benefits eligibility
earlier on that's a huge subject we need
to be able to get to the second tier and
do it reliably but there are some things
you can do just by counting words in
this particular case we had a change
that had been talked about in the
organization for a long time we wanted
to change some procedures we could never
make the business case by just counting
those two words across a sound front of
transcripts we were able to make the
business case to change the IVR system
that change will roll out at the end of
this month we expect that to cut the
number of calls we have by about 20
sent in a year that will pay for our
investment in this project
now this make this situation may not
apply in your business but we're pretty
sure from what we've been finding
looking at the transcripts in depth that
everybody has some kind of problem like
this there's something there but it's
buried at the moment and the last one
tying back to IVR systems again is how
many people here like going through long
IVR menus right well it shows up when
you talk to the agent at the end of it
and we can measure that and we tied back
the sentiment scores and particularly
the negative sentences in the call to
they track the path through the IVR
system so keep them short okay that's
some of the examples of analytics we've
been able to do on this later now I'd
like to take this go a little bit
technical and talk about how we built
this we built it in a framework that's
very likely one that down just outlined
to you we upload our recordings into the
cloud and when you upload the recording
to the storage bucket it triggers a
cloud function this entirely server list
pipeline it's scalable horizontally and
vertically
once that cloud function finishes
processing they transcribe interface
writes the output back as the transcript
record into it into the same storage
bucket it triggers another instance of
the cloud function and we just cascade
through those instances until we've got
all our processing done right we found
that this is a very reliable way of
doing it it's straightforward to deploy
it runs very well we can scale it
vertically as well scales very well with
increasing volumes in a single project
it's also easy to scale horizontally if
we've got a slightly different problem
we want to work on or we want to process
a data set for somebody else we just
spin up another project install all
these software and go and because it's
all cloud function based it so it's a
quick deployment we can spin up a
project in three hours and it only takes
that long as I haven't finished writing
the automation script so again a little
bit about how we build this we develop
in Python we wrap all the Google API Zin
- classes and we use those exclusively
for the cloud and the on-premise
applications this really reduces the
amount of effort we have to put in on
building out a new application to handle
configuration exceptions retries all
those kinds of things it's also turns
out to be really essential for handling
the results speech-to-text gives the
results back in a very natural format
for speech to text their word timings
and their words natural language gives
us back the sentiment without analysis
in the natural format it's sentences in
character offset because when they built
that didn't they don't have word timings
information we have to cross-reference
all of those and we found this as we've
looked into other google api's that we
there's a lot of work in just
integrating all of this together okay
what I'd like to do now is run a short
demo dan talked about the visualizations
okay if you cut it over thank you right
so this is running on a data set in the
cloud in one of our cloud projects and
the data volume you can see the core
volume here I poured a week of core data
to build to build it to this top level
template so this is a real week from
about three weeks ago and you can see
we've got an average sentiment over all
the calls we've got the average agent
talk time client talk time silence and
so on we can we can go down we can plot
this you can see the time lines you can
see that our customer service center is
open from 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. but
very few people call after 6:00 p.m.
right and as and below that we have the
call log we can pick out a particular
call we've built obviously it's on the
Google cloud platform there's got to be
a search engine in there somewhere
and we have the ability to do search
this at the moment it's just a dummy we
haven't hooked up the full text search
on the database and it wouldn't actually
be that useful because for this demo I
had to use redacted transcripts we're a
HIPAA company
I've only read that got two of them
redacted in here so the word cloud works
you can see the evidence of the
redaction how the tax come in but if you
click on a word it will rearrange for
you but with only two recordings in
there it doesn't change much and then
finally the idea is that a customer
service team leader will be able to use
this kind of dashboard and drill into a
particular call and we can do that as
well takes a moment to load you can see
we've got the same kind of parameter
sets up at the top they're just the
measurements for the individual call and
then we have the sentiment timeline here
so this is something that makes specific
for an individual call the aggregate
graph I showed you earlier and it's a
useful tool so here we've got a large
negative sentiment what went on so it
brings up the sentence down the bottom
and it's not really emotional negative
sentiment here this is factual right one
of the problems about doing this only on
text is you don't only thirty dollars
were covered and that's why we sent you
that check for $30 so yeah the only
thing Delta P exactly the other so our
agent wasn't being emotionally negative
but it was negative information that's
where we run into the limits of dealing
with text and we would need another
method there's other tools we've got in
here and I've got just over two minutes
left I'm sorry
so we looking at the entity transcript
we can pull up things like the
organization and highlight those in the
whole text and below that obviously at
some point you want to look at the
listing of the call and we have the
diary's listing which is tagged by agent
and client and obviously we can identify
the agent because for us the initial
greeting is fairly standard alright so
one final thing
you're very welcome well you have a
great day thank you for calling you have
a happy new year thank you thank you yes
what's that
speck to you Dan thank you Kevin
can we go back to the slice so you know
I see that and I get excited so it's
pretty amazing that you could do that
and like two weeks basically you know go
from audio to have like complete
dashboard with visualization of
everything that you want it's clearly
not enough to kind of do everything you
would need in a large call center but we
have a lot of partners that can help
turn it into whatever you need so if
you're interested in more information
about the speech analytics framework
there's a link at the top just go to
bitly s - a - f all of the components
that we talked about today are all
available in our larger solution for
contact centers called contact center AI
that's the URL for that there's also a
session about it tomorrow so please go
there if you want more information about
that and then if you want to learn more
about endless streaming and the new
speech context features we demoed at the
beginning go to that bitly slash GCP -
next 19 - speech and that if you sign up
there then we'll send you information
when it's when it's available to test so
we have a half minute do you guys want
to give try one more bonus demo okay
let's try and do it quickly can we
switch back to the demos please
okay so there's someone here speaking to
language other than English
yeah which language
okay let's test this with Spanish
welcome everyone to Google cloud next
and I hope you're having a great week
here in San Francisco les damos la
bienvenida those who will close the
espero que tengan una excelente semana a
key in San Francisco how was it it was
accurate okay so what you're seeing here
is three things speech-to-text together
with cloud translation and then
text-to-speech all coming together to be
your sort of real-time translator and
why don't you want to show you now
there's this cool device you can't
really see it for those that are far
away but I'm holding like a small device
in my hand and it's from a company
called source necks they released this
device and I'm going to talk to it right
now I'm holding this cool device in my
hand and I'm wondering what it can do
anyone speak Russian here yeah okay
hopefully was that accurate I don't
think so but that's probably coming soon
yeah we haven't released text-to-speech
in Hindi yet but stay tuned but anyway
yeah if you want more information about
this stuff they will launch this a while
back oops sorry and three hundred
thousand are already sold so pretty
exciting let me go back to the links and
you can see there so while we're doing
that I don't think we have Oh
please leave feedback the organizers
were very clear it would be great if we
can get as much feedback as possible
from as many of you tell us if you
enjoyed the session
if you didn't you know what you hear
want to hear more when you what you want
to hear less
[Music]